and that means that our gold medal will
be going to director Rafael Cortina for
his film bottled up Raphael well thank
you guys for coming out this is a huge
crowd and thank you Bob everywhere you
go you seem to bring a full house
at the 2013 Academy Awards it's reported
that all nominees were given a gift bag
worth forty five thousand dollars all
day today I've been looking for someone
to hand me that glam bag with facelifts
and Caribbean vacations if I miss that
table please someone pointed out after
the show it in all seriousness it's a
huge honor to be up here filmmaking is
by no means one man show and I wouldn't
be receiving this award if I hadn't
surrounded myself with a cast and crew
who really wake up every day to get
better at what they do there should be
about 25 other people on stage
celebrating and holding this piece of
hardware you guys are remarkable and
thanks for coming out you know four
years ago I decided to go to Occidental
College at turning down some some of the
more storage film schools because I
wanted a liberal arts education so I
could you know learn how to communicate
and think effectively and it's been a
real treat I want to thank everyone
there who helped me achieve earlier
today I got a phone call from President
Obama congratulating me on my award and
he he wanted me to tell the
administration that although he went
there for two years please please please
stop referring to him as an alum so I
want to pass that along but uh on a
serious note i'm glad i went to
Occidental and i'm glad that you know
that in compromise my chance to be here
in the great company that I am today
much love to my family of friends in and
and and family my family of friends and
relatives who keep me love day in and
day out my mom couldn't be here tonight
because across the country just a few
hours ago she walked up a stage also and
received her bachelor's degree she
having encouraged me every day to focus
and work hard I'm proud that she's one
of the few people who follows the advice
she gives thank you to all my
Kickstarter producers congratulations
mom thank you to my intrepid a
co-producer and more importantly
girlfriend Mary and of course thank you
to the Academy everyone have a great